hey guys it is at altamonte say my name
is Jess McDonald and you're watching
games bunnies first up today you need 12
no longer about what's going to be in
the newest ps4 system update since Sony
have come right out and told you Sony
Computer Entertainment Australia have
dropped the details on update 2.5 Oh
code names Yukimura this update will do
a bunch of things including introducing
that suspend resume feature and upping
the streaming frame rate from 30 to 60
frames per second while using remote
play and share play the console will now
take a screenshot the moment you earn a
trophy and you can import facebook
friends directly to your ps4 friends
list user interface options are also
coming including the ability to change
fonts contrast and the implementation of
text to speech Sony are still simply
saying the update will arrive sometime
soon but you can check out the full list
of features on gamespot things aren't
all hugs and puppies for Sony though as
a PlayStation users account has been
hacked Sony aren't helping out all that
much and the internet is getting mad
reddit user codger has said that six
hundred dollars worth of content has
been bought from his account without his
permission and that his ps4 had been
deactivated from PSN with another
unknown system taking its place as the
primary console on his account katja
reported that after talking to sony they
said they could only refund 150 of the
600 bucks due to PSN wallet restrictions
and the refund needed to be install
credit small sony also said that if the
user escalates the issue with his bank
his account will be banned which
inherently wipes his legitimately
purchased licenses permanently on top of
all that / Sony policy a new ps4 cannot
be bound to an account for six months
finally today titanfall 2 is indeed
coming according to develop a respawn
respawn co-founder Vince Zampella had
confirmed that titanfall 2
is in development and will be
multi-platform presumably making an
appearance on ps4 as well as xbox one
and pc when asked about the possibility
of a more fleshed out single-player
campaign Zampella said of the first
titan pool game I wouldn't have done it
differently we put some single-player
elements in there though and try to mix
it up maybe we could have mixed things
up a bit better because some people blew
right by it and didn't even see it
because there was so much action
happening around it it's tough because
if you hit people over the head with it
it becomes intrusive and there are
people who don't want or care about it
let me know down in the comments if you
think Sony is handling this hacking
situation well and what you think should
or shouldn't be done you can head to
gain spot where we've got news on
blood-borne going gold and homefront
through getting a delay those are all
the things that I have to tell you about
today but do remember that tomorrow I'll
have my top five stories of the whole
gaming week ready to go for you so we
shall stop by then